gary uh when you when you're looking at
the game of chess what do you how do you
see the game like from your lens if you
put your lens on so we can learn from
you do you look at it as war do you look
at it as
uh uh purely from a mathematics you know
point of view how are you looking at the
game
uh it's it's a game so what's the i
don't think it's it's mathematics or or
or any other science it's it requires a
lot of preparation so i
um i'm still very passionate about the
game so i love the game i i like
watching i love watching the games i
just playing you know online and just
doing exhibitions so it still
takes a considerable part of my life
uh again i just know my limitations that
i'm no longer a professional player i'm
probably the strongest amateur on the
planet
uh
um but um
uh when i play chess it's
it was everything so as again
you play you have to invest you know all
you have into the game so whether it's
you may call it a war it's a side it may
call psychological warfare because we're
sitting against each other and it's just
it's the if
thanks to the queen's gambit i think a
lot of people recognize the intensity of
the game
so i i was very proud that you know as
an advisor to scott frank so i added so
many details that made it very realistic
and and for those because very often i'm
being asked you know what are the
pictures i'm sure many of you watch this
the series that's this was best harmon
looking at the ceiling with the pic they
said oh it's it's it's hollywood i said
no no that's not hollywood it's a hole
with production but that's exactly how
many of us you know thought during the
game just you look at the board but then
again take your eyes away that's this is
the way that you can just somehow
refresh your your
attitude so and just to find some new
new ideas because we don't have to look
at the board just to analyze it so um i
you know i again enjoyed it immensely
and and i can i
it was a never-ending
process of acquiring data analyzing it
and coming up with new ideas fresh ideas
yeah i i ask it for a reason i'll get to
my question in a minute here but let me
go in a different direction so in
business world you'll have a business
plan
write a business plan and here's what
we're going to do q1 this month second
quarter third quarter fourth quarter and
then we're going to expand here we're
gonna take this cap and i'm gonna hire
five employees here we're gonna go to
this office anyways you put a business
plan together
and then covet happens and then
somebody in your company leaves and goes
to the competitor they take three
clients away from you things adjust how
much of the game you play
you play because you're initiating and
making can react to you and how much of
it is it you're reacting to your
opponent's moves
um
i think when people talked about charles
darwin i think often they got it wrong
because actually the darwin
theory said that it's not the
strongest peace
species
that survive
not the smartest
but the most adaptable to change
that's it so it's about your ability to
adapt and these days it's the most
valuable quality power of guaranteed
success
as you said all it happens things can
happen
and it's just it's it's it's you know
and
and that's why you know i always argued
and it's it's my book in a special
chapter how lafayette has a special
chapter called attack disadvantage
yes people know that if you are in the
attack you take risk
but there was also benefits because you
are ahead
you you can be ahead of the just on this
curve and see what's happening there so
i think these days
attackers advantage is more valuable
than ever
wow
because because again it's
taking risk is risky
not taking risk is much riskier
what split would you put on that 80 20
70 i don't know this is okay that's that
depends but it's you know it's for so
long
we knew that you know that's the um
the uh philosophy of business was to
mitigate risk how to reduce it
and by the way this is once i did an
experiment so um
uh you can use a google engram
and you can look at the books for 100
years
and and find out how certain words have
been used
and uh you know you can check and it's
it's always you know shows the the the
uh the change in the public attitude and
and technology you put the word computer
you put it on the phone so phone goes up
and then a little bit down and then with
mobile phones goes up against there's
only one word that i found that that
didn't behave you know following the
pattern
it's called risk
until mid late 60s it was almost
non-existing
and then it jumped
exponentially
we discovered risk
and we wanted to mitigate this risk
we wanted to handle it we want to
minimize it
forgetting the fact that oh if you
minimize risk you also have to sacrifice
benefits
ah we can print money of course
that's what we've been doing for a long
time
so to compensate
but it's it's it's you know it's insane
just even to think you know how many
great things happened in the past
because people didn't you know pay much
attention to risk
the every of you has a mobile device
that is 10
000 times more powerful
than all computing power of nasa in 1969
when americans landed in the on the moon
so
maybe that's that's happened because
they couldn't calculate the risk
because today we would know that the
risk of losing the crew would be 25 to
30 percent
show me the president of the united
states would authorize such a mission
today so again is this discovering risk
has consequences
yeah risk risk is a problem but you know
it's the you know we we build systems
you know that's that had to make sure
that you know no risk will find a whole
to uh jeopardize our business
yeah it's this by
fda regulations you know penicillin
would be banned today the first test
because every person shows allergy some
people say even maybe even tylenol will
not make it through
so what happened during the pandemics
all of a sudden
rules changed
because the companies that abandoned
research in antibiotics and vaccines for
a simple reason
because 95
90 was not good
it 99.9 percent you know could lead to a
trouble you know with a army of lawyers
you know going after you if you fail
once but now we needed something we need
a miracle
and and i think that's now we're seeing
this change in this attitude it's more
and more people recognize that you know
you have to incorporate risk yes
it's risky yes you can lose but you have
potential benefits at the end of the day
that's that's about capitalism
you just said
yeah
it's the
you know
it's a the winston churchill said that
uh the inherit wise of capitalism
is an equal um distribution of the
blessing of blessings
but the
inherent
virtue of socialism is equal sharing of
miseries
so
yeah we you know we have to take out we
have to take our chances yes and and i
think again this is we have something
that was not available in 1969 or in the
70s or the 80s we have these very
powerful devices
you know just how do we use them you
know do we use them wisely do we use
them effectively
i don't think so
so just you know find a way to utilize
this enormous power that have been
created in the free world so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]